- Möchtest du ein Plätzchen? Hab' ich
heute Morgen frisch gebacken.
- Vielen Dank!
- Also, ich will auch eins!
- Weil du so lieb „bitte“ gesagt hast?
- Hm ...
Die sind aber nicht von dir!
- Wieso nicht?
- Weil die so wahnsinnig lecker sind.
- Ja! Lecker!
- Gut. Das war dein letztes.
Lisa, möchtest du auch ein Plätzchen?
- Danke!
- Was machst du denn da?
- Ähm, ich muss morgen das Thema
Recycling und Umweltschutz
im Unterricht behandeln.
Aber ich weiß noch nicht, wie.
- Und wieso? Wo ist das Problem?
- Na, das Thema ist total wichtig.
Aber wenn der Unterricht
nicht spannend ist,
dann ist es total langweilig.
- Langweilig?
Also pass mal auf:
Wenn wir unseren Planeten
weiterhin so ausbeuten,
dann brauchen wir
2030 mindestens zwei Erden.
Und du kannst deinen Schülern auch sagen,
dass jeden Tag 130 Tierarten aussterben.
Nur mal so.
- Was?
- Insekten zählen auch dazu.
- Also je statistischer das Thema,
desto langweiliger wird es.
- Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
- Doch, das ist viel zu abstrakt.
Meine Schüler sollen ja selber aktiv werden.
Sie sollen ein
Umweltbewusstsein entwickeln
und sich über ihr
Konsumverhalten klar werden.
- Na ja, es reicht ja eigentlich schon,
wenn du mal 'ne Woche kein Plastik kaufst.
Das Zeug ist sowas von umweltschädlich.
- Das ist super!
- Ach, das ist super?
Das ist ultralangweilig!
- Also, wenn die mal eine Woche
auf Plastik verzichten würden,
dann würden sie ja merken,
was alles aus Plastik ist.
Das ist toll!
- Ja!
- Also, also hier sitzt ein Mensch
mit zwei Gehirnen, ganz klar.
Und vielen Plätzchen.
- Was ist … was ist Gehirn?